[Music]
inside of you is brought to you by
better help
i don't know what i would do without
therapy i really i really don't
uh there was a time when i wasn't on
therapy wasn't in therapy
um and i really had no platform or no
nobody to bounce things off of things
that i was feeling and i was
you know things that get bottled up
inside ryan
well i love better help and i love what
they do
it's because the more you talk about
something
the less it has a hold on you and the
more
uh i believe that these things that are
haunting you or causing you pain they
you're relieved they they start to
dissipate they start to go away
and i really truly believe and i've
talked to so many friends and if you
listen to the show you know
how important therapy is and can be
and you know they say well it doesn't
have to be for everybody well
i think it does i think everybody should
talk to someone
objectively that they don't you know
it's it's when i talk to you
i talk i can't my darkest weirdest
thoughts i can't really
express but when i can trust a therapist
that i'm sitting across from
to express these things i i find it um
incredibly healthy and helpful i i leave
the therapy session
feeling better when i start it i'm like
oh god i don't want to talk i don't want
to talk i don't want to
and by the end of it i notice such a
shift
in my energy therapy really is whatever
you want it to be
um you need to get some tools to help
with you know your motivation depression
whatever the problems you might be
having
it's time to stop being ashamed of
normal human struggles and start feeling
better because you
deserve to be happy better help is
customized online therapy they offer
video
phone even live chat sessions with your
therapist
so you don't have to see anyone on
camera if you don't want to i like to
see the person but you don't have to see
them
it's much more affordable than in in
person therapy and i could tell you that
by from experience
we're talking substantial i mean the
therapists that are you know especially
in la are quite expensive better help
is incredibly affordable join the
millions of people who are seeing what
therapy is really about
it may or may not be for you but it's
worth looking into because you are
your greatest asset this podcast is
sponsored by
betterhelp and inside of you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp.com
inside tom rosenbaum sent you for god's
sakes get some help get some therapy
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rose mom thank you for joining
us
uh good morning good afternoon good
evening i i don't know what day you're
watching this maybe you're watching it
years later months later
you didn't watch when it first came out
or listened but that you're here with us
so i appreciate that we had a great
guest today
um i worked with him in sweet november
we
had a kissing scene that didn't make it
that cut um you know from harry potter
the patriot
tons of stuff we'll get into him but uh
first i gotta ask ryan what the hell is
going on with him today
cause he's a little out there yeah no
i've got a lot a lot of stuff going on
this week and uh
that's it well you know what it's either
you do too much
and you're stressed you do too little
and you're stressed you the proverbial
you
sure or it's right in the maybe there's
some porridge the porridge the middle i
think we're all missing a little bit of
porridge in our lives
guys make some porridge just is that is
that the right saying porridge
porridge say it say the word porridge if
you're driving right now i just say
porridge
porridge it just sounds wrong porridge
uh thanks again for ever everyone for uh
listening to the podcast for sticking
with the podcast
um tell your friends let them know uh
subscribe if you haven't subscribed if
you're here for jason isaacs
love you to stick around and learn
something with us i'm always learning
stuff from the guests
and i think you will too you could
subscribe where ryan
uh at youtube.com inside of you with
michael rosenbaum for the youtube
podcast or you can just follow on uh
twitter insideofypod uh instagram
facebook at
you podcast they're right here you can
see them too yeah so at
or and you can email hello
insideablepodcast.com
that's right if you have any questions
we don't answer them right away we get
to them
quite infrequently it's just i have so
much going on and i don't have a lot of
people helping me out with that so
uh you know ryan's editing price is
producing
i'm doing the show and a bunch of other
stuff and doing the patreon if you if
you don't know what patreon is um
i have a lot of patrons and they support
the show in other ways and it's a big
family and
join patreon.com inside of you
patreon.com inside of you and uh i'll
send you a message after you join
it's a nice family but thank you for
listening guys thanks for tuning in
uh we've got some great guests and you
know we've had some great guests zach
levi coming back you think okay it's his
third time who wants to listen to the
third time but you know what it
it he really opened up and i freaking
loved it i loved him he was talking
about the medications he's on he's
pretty much telling the world that
it's okay to be a little broken and you
got to really do the work you got to do
the work
yeah hey guys if you're uh enjoying
sometimes you hear the music playing
that's my band uh sunspin we have a uh
album out right here you see that
it's called best days sunspin is the
band best days is the album and you can
get it at
sunspin.com along with awesome merch
and all that jazz and you can also get
awesome inside of you stuff
and lex luthor autographs and all that
[ __ ] at the inside of you online store
we've got small the lunch boxes
we also have sunspend lunch boxes that
we sign and
so there's a lot of good stuff there and
i just want to say thanks again for for
for listening and uh tuning in
it's been you know a tough week i'm
having problems waking up in the morning
really i just have a i have a tough time
um
i wake up the same time around 7 00 am
and then i make some coffee and i feed
the dogs and i do my routine
but i just feel heavy in the face just
like ah i just could fall asleep
and maybe it's the meds i don't know i
take meds when i
when i wake up a small amount of meds
uh just for you know a little anxiety
stuff and whatever but
you know but i do feel heavy maybe it
just takes some people a couple hours to
wake up is that possible
because i never felt like this before
really usually i'm within an hour
now it's like three hours i think it i
think having
something to do having a purpose in the
morning
as you suck down isn't that an is that
merch
is on the side of you i am sipping down
some decaf coffee maybe that's my
problem the decaf
you need the coffee yeah my coffee is
just hitting i'm like
yeah i don't know i'm you know what i
want to be on that
hot wing show yeah you should do that
but i think i would post
i i would be the worst guest ever
because after three i'm not good with
hot stuff
everybody says that everyone is on that
show says that but they all they all
make it
no no i would make this i don't think i
think i would die probably by
wing five what's it called hot ones
hot ones but he gets huge guests i'm not
a big star like that
who knows we're gonna go from will
ferrell doing hot wings to michael
rosenbaum
it's gonna go from 10 million views to
like 200.
but i'll make it funny because i'll
freak out and i'll i'll probably fall
off the chair i'll probably
scream we could just do it here you have
your own platform
why don't we do our own hot wings say
since he won't beat me on his show
michael rose's mom decided to do
his own hot stuff hot stuff hot ones hot
ones
with ryan yeah and we sat here for an
episode and just ate hot wings
this is yeah it might get a couple
hundred views yeah anyway i was going to
talk more today but i'm not going to
let's get into this guest this is
uh you know i i've known this guy a long
time
we did sweet november together was with
charlize throne and and ken aries he's
done tons of movies
he's an incredible actor my mother never
talks about my acting but always talks
about his
this is uh he's got some great stories
and i think you're gonna really enjoy
this so
um let's get inside of jason isaacs
it's my point of view
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
look at that you look good thanks very
much like a little little pro thing here
what do you think
it's not as big as fluffy as yours
obviously what are we talking about
i haven't got one what do you call the
big uh the spongy thing i'm going to
those
oh you mean these little uh the condoms
for the microphone
yeah i've got a little i've got a pop
shield so they're all over the mic well
yeah
that's because you do a lot of
voiceovers and stuff right you got to
have that little do some voiceovers i'll
be doing i said not recently not for
money i've been doing charity
voiceovers and and hosting charity
callers and uh charity appeals
non-stop for the last six months i feel
so [ __ ] guilty because
people don't have any money and people
are terrified but on the other hand the
charities have all run out of money
completely
so uh yeah i bought myself a bunch of
equipment and then i've done a lot of
charity work
you got to feel good about that though
come on i do i mean i was encouraged to
get it by my voice over agent who said
the work will come flooding in
and it hasn't even trickled him but you
know uh mine's
ours is not the reason why it's all fine
voice overs are actually
i think harder to get than actual acting
gigs
i mean they're not in uh in england in
america yeah so i
when i moved to the states i i was doing
a lot of voiceovers in england
and you just get booked you just they go
i would like you to do the voice of
whatever the hell it is and he said i'm
in the studio and you do it
so my agent goes uh i have a friend in
america who's an american voice
celebration i'll you can get one there
i'm like yes
and i just figured i would just slide
into doing it there
it's a very different world it really is
i'd go in somewhere
and i didn't quite understand the
concept of audition to be 50 people it
was like being on the voice
and narrow it down to ten and five and
three people yeah you don't get it and
you go
[ __ ] this i've been here all day i'm not
doing that anymore so i started to do
cartoons i did a lot of cartoons which i
know you did
well actually and video games yeah
before you know we'll get into that but
uh
you know how we met obviously we met
wait oh we're recording we're on
okay oh yeah i mean i just like you know
it's
okay so we should tell the three people
listening uh or watching oh there's
actually
millions of people here i wouldn't say
millions would you tell them how we met
all right how did hold on you look
exactly the same my eyes are fading but
you look exactly hold on a second i got
an old dog he's barking
he never does this he's old though it's
control he just hears a jew and starts
barking
yeah they're well-trained here's a jew
yeah well he has two jews talking and
they're just upset that's true two or
two jews
i never thought how do we be tell tell
us how defamatory we're gonna be do we
want lawsuits here well you know it's
funny because
all right so we're not now i mean we
could say whatever we want people uh
people will like it i hope um so
i i auditioned for sweet november and i
met with pat o'connor
who directed he directed circle of
friends and i remember uh
i didn't know this but i auditioned for
your role and i didn't know that you
were already their guy but your your
schedule was conflicting
so like you were in the
i remember because i didn't even know i
was up against anybody i mean obviously
you're up against everybody
but uh pat o'connor calls me and he has
it
michael um you know uh listen like you
gave a great audition
and um or you know and that whole thing
you do it much better because you were
on a show where you no no i was looking
i wouldn't even dare to do his irish
accent but he was
almost dead but he backed off and he was
like floating
um no i don't know what it was but he
said to me he says listen you have a
great audition and everything and
you know you're great for the role but
we have this actor that's
on hold for that's why we were reading
other actors because he's
he's if his schedule doesn't work i'd
like you to play this character
[ __ ] so i was supposed to play you must
have hated me for decades now no
i never did it all but he said listen
there's this other role i doesn't seem
as important
but it's his lover and we'll do what we
can and we'll just make you feel like
one
it's not a very big cast and we want you
to come play with us and so i came to
san francisco i met you we went golfing
we had time to do
things we hung out with uh keanu and
charlize a little
and i remember we were
he pat said hey why don't you guys just
start improvising something on set
so let me just build back up to that so
when i because i when i was off the job
i didn't want to take it i just done the
patriot and i like the idea of playing
someone who
certainly surprises the audience by
turning out to be a drag queen
but it just didn't i wasn't in love with
the script and he said to me
he phoned me up he said look we have
mutual friends i know you like to
improvise
you can't improvise most of it kiana's
in the scenes with you i don't think
that'd be fair to him
but there will be a scene where i will
let you completely off the leash and i
think i have a very good time
we've got a fantastic guy playing your
boyfriend i think you know it's really
going to kick off
so i i was very well behaved the rest of
the film and i was so looking forward
to our scene together no one the
audience doesn't know that i'm a dragon
or it doesn't know i'm gay
who thinks that i'm a love rifle friend
he turns up at our front door
first of all i had said before we went
out i said the production listen i'm
playing a drag queen i don't know any
is there anywhere can you think of
anyone find someone i could come
research and they went
honey we're in san francisco throw us
down
and so i went out to a bunch of drag
bars and it was quite shocking to me you
know i
i funny if i'd had a trans friend before
but i had never been around
transvestites you know and i just didn't
know that drag wasn't about passing for
a woman and i went to these bars i'm
like oh these guys
some of them have mustaches they look
like puerto rican truck drivers in the
frock am i so i i
was allowed off the hook i didn't have
to pass for a woman uh but i
was given carte blanche to dress in
anything i wanted
so i went and picked his stuff and i did
my fingernails and a wig and stuff
and i looked in the mirror and i went
[ __ ] me that's exactly what my
my mother looked like when i was growing
up
there's a picture i mean she was much
but she's a very very pretty woman but i
had approximated
unconsciously my mother in the 60s
anyway but we get to the thing it's you
and i
we're going to do a scene and i just
remember pat going okay you've been very
good well-behaved
you've given keanu his cues or because
he likes to have you know he's a
different kind of actor like his cues
now [ __ ] him up the character would be
to come in the room
and not know what's going on and be
really thrown you and michael
[ __ ] him up and then we just i don't
know
you take it over i had the best time the
best time and i remember do you remember
he said
uh i just had the sound guy record us so
go listen to what you did and kind of
[ __ ] around and see what you can come up
with
so we improvised then we heard kind of
what we did we'll keep that and then
we'll add
and then we'll it was just kind of light
and fun and i had so much fun
he rolled until the this is back in the
days of film he wrote until the mags ran
out and then rolled again really
we're all having a good time yeah and he
called me at some point or i had to do
adr or something
he said the scene is like 20 minutes
long and it's everybody's favorite pit
in the scene
i've got to cut it down to like two or
three minutes because it's just it's
upending the whole thing
you know there's a lovely romantic film
then this is just a genius comedy set
piece
and then it's back to romance you're
like bring those guys back on again so
somewhere there is a 20-minute short
film
starring you and i doing stuff which we
probably wouldn't be allowed to do today
oh it was it was fun though i had a
great time and uh
you know working with you and i could
see that kind of uh
you know that that flicker in your eye
that sort of that
i don't know you have that air about you
that energy that
you know you're obviously super talented
but just a long time ago
but you just and by the way i think
you're probably just getting married
right around then
weren't you uh we were
no no we went i went when did we do it
we did 2 000
right yeah you were married and what
2001. no 2001 uh
uh yeah maybe i didn't come over no no
no because 2001
i went to black hole down and uh we were
trying to get pregnant and really
let me out of the last seems incredibly
nice i could go and see an ivf doctor in
new york
so there's a scene in which i meant to
be in which i'm not in uh and when we
got pregnant and then
when we were pregnant we were in l.a
it's just so unromantic
and uh my wife was sick and uh we didn't
know whether to fly home or not we found
a doctor in the uk and he said
you should go to an emergency room the
thing she's got you should go and check
out for a blood clot
i thought well we thought [ __ ] we don't
have any medical insurance i've got sags
she's got nothing
so we went to a registry office on
wilson boulevard we called two of our
friends who came
and we all swore an oath of silence that
we would never tell anyone we were
married there because we wanted to have
a proper wedding
and invite friends and hopefully they'd
fly overseas and make a fuss and
if they knew you know so we came back to
england i didn't tell anyone didn't tell
my friends
didn't tell my family anything and we
were at dinner a couple months later
with this
friend of ours and actress and she said
you know since the two years you guys
got married and i said we're not married
and she went
chase emma told everyone
oh my god she went yeah i could sorry i
couldn't keep it in so we never did do
the proper wedding thing but it was uh
it was like a year and a half after we
worked again wow and you guys have been
together for
20 years 500 years 30 something years
we're still trying to get one
continuously good week
when we do we'll we'll assess the
situation yeah i don't know how you do
that man see i'm i'm
somewhat single i guess perpetually
and i just feel like you know i'm 48
years old
could you imagine yourself alone could
you imagine yourself
not having emma
no no no i thought you're gonna say no
i she's my glue i can't really well the
truth is we're actors right i don't know
what i'm gonna do when i grow up still
so
and i'm ten years older nine years older
so yeah i can imagine myself as a wizard
i can imagine myself in a
spaceship i can imagine like you know
this is my life i mean
you know emerald is my life my kids are
my life this is my life but i also want
a hundred other lives
i want the life where i'm you know
roaming around i want to be david
carradine in kung fu i want to be
climbing
mountains and i want to be a you know i
want to
there's a million things uh lives that
i'd like to live i get to live
you know barely a fraction of one of
them but at least vicariously
the most fun thing i think the most fun
thing about acting when
in normal times is i get to shadow
people and then for
moments pretend i'm them sometimes so
i've i've been lucky enough to shadow
police and soldiers
and prostitutes and pimps and uh
politicians and many things that don't
give a pay you know so i i uh
and each time i think oh that could have
been me i wonder what my life would be
like that person
so yeah i love emma this is who i am
this is where i'm anchored in the world
but
i can imagine a million other lives what
would you do the grass is
often greener if you're not careful the
grass will always seem greener yes
what would you do though i have a glass
sound if you can see this what is it
certainly you won't see it on an audio
podcast
it says pessimist an optimist but i wish
someone had made a glass where you could
just fill the top off
and only had the pessimist staff phil
because i'm often that too yeah i i
think we all are
good god i wish i'd get out of my way so
you're single have you had long
relationships
yeah here we go we're turning we this
always happens by the way
becomes the therapist i adore you and i
haven't seen you between something i
know
uh you know i've had some you know three
we saw each other once
outside the club didn't we yeah yeah
club listen a club that's at a
restaurant a restaurant yeah
you call them clubs in in england right
yeah yeah yeah yeah you know i i date
i've had a three-year relationship i had
a year relationship but you know i just
i see all the dysfunction around me and
i see the unhappiness around me and then
the few moments you see that
oh wow that couple really works or you
see my grandparents married for 72 years
and it gives you hope but then i think i
had there was so much
[ __ ] i went through you know growing up
that you're like i don't think i should
get married i don't i don't know i don't
know
it's a ton of compromise it is it is
everything involves a ton of compromise
being single does being
in a relationship because i'm selfish
you could probably be
shellfish you could be shellfish
extremely selfish and uh
yeah i see other couples i remember
there was this couple when i was in
drama school
my friend eric's parents were both child
psychologists
and they seemed so my parents were not
happy i don't remember one moment of
happiness growing up seeing
any any joy between them or you know
from each other
um and seeing this couple they were
incredible we all felt the same way all
of uh
eric's friends and we i went and asked
them separately they were staying with
us we shared a bomb
and i asked them separately i said why
your marriage seems
crazy happy i've never seen anything
like it in my life what is it they both
said separately
well i just devote myself to
his happiness or her happiness which at
the time seemed great now i think that's
the definition of codependency
or whatever it is something but whatever
it seemed to work for them um
i don't know i mean i it's you know in
the end we born alone and we die alone
and
these are the this is the choice i made
i'm not a leaver emma's not a leaver
so we're in it for thick or thin is that
a bad thing though jason is it a bad
thing to because you know some people
say you know have your own
agenda have your own happiness but is
there something to be said about
meeting someone who really just loves
being around you and wants to make you
happy
i mean that is codependency i didn't
meet that person i i think i met someone
who is more healthy and more balanced
than that
exactly but you know i i you know i mean
look if
you meet someone and they just love
doing what you love to do
and that's their fun they just love
being around you and doing the things
that you like and you're like well let's
do something you like but they don't
really have much to offer or they never
really ask
to say you know they never suggest oh
why don't we do this they just go along
with you
will that get boring i don't know yes i
think so i think it would be
very very boring to be utterly dominant
i'd like it for a week or two
or even an hour for anybody to think
that what i said was impressive or
interesting on the other hand look i'm
an actor and i get
um sometimes i get a monstrously
grotesquely undue amount of
status from people socially uh some
certainly you know from from people who
like the work or
fans and and the a film set is a a very
rigid almost you know
ancient egyptian hierarchy and you get
all that status too
um so if my wife was even
microscopically impressed by me it would
probably be you know
it would it would be awful and damaging
so she's no interest in
watching anything i do work wise she
won't listen to this podcast no
she's not just the the public performing
side of me she's
not not just well even vaguely
interesting she doesn't come to a
premiere with you she didn't see the
patriots it's different
premieres different because you know
it's it would be weird if she did by the
way she didn't come to all of them by
any means
and uh she doesn't you know i've just
been doing a bunch of publicity the last
couple weeks this is not
by the way and you know as you know i'm
not on the publicity trail but i was
last week doing a bunch of junky things
for a film called skyfire this uh
chinese volcano film how is that was it
fun yeah yeah it's amazing but anyway
what are we gonna say is
i was in the newspapers there's
magazines on the radio stations you know
there's [ __ ] that happens when a film
comes
has no idea she didn't read the papers
she didn't listen to the interviews
she hasn't watched the film which we've
got you know a link to and stuff and
that's probably
uh incredibly healthy uh but it doesn't
feed my
ever get a grasping ego my my bottomless
pit of need for
for praise but that's maybe why we're
still married after 32 years does she
say
you're raising children she's doing her
half you're doing your half
every once in a while do you ever hear
jason
you were really great in that oh in that
no i i mean if i if she comes down in
the morning and i've cleaned the kitchen
up
and done the bins yeah if i decide i'll
do the school run although i did it in
the morning yeah the normal stuff of
life if i'm kind
if i praise her if i you know if i uh do
something that hasn't been asked for if
i
cook dinner and whatever just the normal
things in life if i'm
uh she's impressed by she's not
impressed by those things i do
professionally or how much
command i have socially and i think
that's probably really helpful yeah
it's really healthy you know didn't gary
newman the pop star marry the president
of his fan club
i'm not sure well maybe they're still
incredibly happy gary for listening to
this i apologize
but i'll tell you what jason priestley
married a fan of his his wife who's
wonderful and they've been married and
have kids that are happy as they're so
it's rare
it does happen but it's probably not you
know you tried to separate that
yeah yeah yeah the only thing is so when
you tell people you're married for 30
odd years and you've been together
forever
they always think oh it's paul newman
john wood and they have this perfect
i don't know anyone who's got the
perfect thing i do know there's people i
think from the outside
wow if only we were like that look at
how great they are with each other and
then they break up where you find out
that they've got a you know basement
full of
uh limbless children or whatever the
hell it is so we're no poster children
for how to conduct ourselves
or sort out problems or arguments we do
our best we try to get better at it
uh there are times where petulant sulky
and stupid there's times we're loving
and fabulous and
you know it is it is it's a marriage
it's it's i remember
a meeting years and years ago you get to
edit this when i'm really [ __ ] boring
right
you're not boring at all this is what
this is i don't know i'm about to be
but oh well then years ago i met um
eds vic and uh marshall huskers who did
30-something i met marshall i think in
london
and he said to me um look uh uh you know
we've seen you working i don't know i do
and what uh but i was doing harry potter
at the time and it was in the gap and
they said we
we used to make television we made a
thing called 30 or something as that
island
no i could recite every word of every
episode you know they said well you
must be young watching i said i don't
know why i must have been 18 to 19. i
loved 30 something
i loved the fact he created tim
busfield's character elliot who was
selfish
and patient spoiled and sulked and just
felt like a real person you know
everybody wanted to be ken olin michael
but i wanted to be tim busfield or
because i've never seen anyone like that
before uh he said well okay well i'm
glad you know it because
we're going to come back to television
and be making these giant movies uh but
we
wanted to see you know we just don't
know any people who've been killed and
we don't know any aliens we don't need
people with superpowers
we want to make a tv show about the [ __ ]
in our lives about a marriage
just you know about the ups and downs of
marriage and how to hold it together and
what happens someone gets cancer and
your kids growing up and
that should be enough drama that's the
drama that most people experience
and i well that sounds amazing and then
i couldn't do it because the schedule
was something and uh
they made it i saw edgewake in the park
years later when i was living in los
angeles walking a dog and i said it's
rick so yeah and i said oh it's jason i
remember years ago i nearly that pilot
with you uh i said how did it go
you know you wanted to see whether you
could make a drama out of just the
simple things in life you went
yeah you can't i went
oh okay he said yeah there's got to be a
murder a homicide or a joke yeah
some kind of other thing going on it's
not enough to have ordinary life
wow marriage don't be envious of it be
who you are and
find your places where you take i think
it must be difficult to be 48
and be prepared to make the amount of
compromises
that it takes to be you know emma and i
have been together so long it will be
to consider not being together would be
seismic but when you meet a new person
you start dating yeah they better be
perfect
you know what they better feel like that
jigsaw better fit perfect they're just
i think it's just it has to just be easy
like it can't there just can't be drama
there can't be like real
sensitive about things you say i mean
look you argue you have things but
it just can't be combative i can't be in
a combative relationship i never really
have there was one
but i just don't want to argue i don't
want to like you know in relationships
and either this one with them or you
know
my friends i see new ones that when
something is going wrong or isn't going
great you think well it's because they
fill in the blank whatever it is right
that's
crazy or they ocd or they brought up my
and and the trick and i don't have it
i'm not i'm absolutely talking the talk
that i can't walk here
the trick is to go what did i do you
know what's my bit
what can i change and it but it's always
there yeah
i found that that's a good line my
relationship yoda advised that
inside of you is brought to you by helix
helix sleep man there's no sleep like
helix i will tell you that right now
i uh you guys know i suffer from back
surgeries
and i'm always looking for a better
mattress a new mattress
something that i could just wake up and
go okay i'm ready for the day
you got to try helix they do this
amazing quiz that takes like two minutes
ryan
and uh it matches your body type
and sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you
well i mean why would you buy a mattress
made for for someone else
yeah i mean if you're taking a quiz and
like oh this is the perfect sleep for
you this is the perfect mattress
if every mattress is the same then i'm
just getting your mattress and you're
getting my mattress and we both sleep
differently
and we both like different mattresses
doesn't make any sense it doesn't make
any sense
with helix you're getting a mattress
that you know will be perfect for the
way
you sleep everybody's unique and helix
knows that so they have several
different mattress models
to choose from they have soft medium and
firm mattresses
mattresses great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot
and even a helix plus mattress for you
uh plus size sleepers
i took the helix quiz you know i'm a
medium
and that's that's what works for me you
know with with my back problems i can't
be too hard
i can't be too soft i've got to be right
down the middle
but take the quiz it takes two minutes
and uh you'll figure that out
so if you're looking for a mattress it's
quite simple
you just take a quiz you order the
mattress that you're matched to
and the mattress comes right to your
door shipped for free
you don't ever need to go to a mattress
store again
just go to helixsleep.com inside take
their two-minute sleep quiz
and they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life got a 10-year
warranty too
you could try it out for a hundred
nights who gives you that risk free
helix helix is offering up to 200 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners
you hear that 200 off all mattresses
and two free pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep dot com
slash inside that's helix sleep dot com
slash inside for up to 200 off
and two free pillows helix
inside of you is brought to you by geico
michael you own this home correct i do
own my home
and that can be stressful in a lot of
different ways
can't ryan it is incredibly stressful
for everyone around the world
the biggest thing that people uh you
know uh have a hard time with is paying
their mortgage paying their rent it's
always the biggest problem you know you
always hear those stories like it's like
you have to be your one week salary
should pay for two mo for for
uh um two weeks salary should pay for
the rent
right isn't that the thing i think so
it's it's definitely tough and what's
even more of a [ __ ] ryan is paying your
mortgage
to one company then paying your auto
policy to
another company then paying this to
another
it's a pain in my ass and that's why
there is geico and that's why geico has
bundling policies it's so simple i don't
i you know they don't even need me to
talk about this they're one of the
biggest companies in the world they know
what they're doing here
they're doing something right look folks
it's it's that easy these bundling
policies you pay one person you pay
geico and you're done with it you're
gonna get a great rate just go
to geico.com you get a quote
you see how much you could save it's
geico
easy visit geico.com today
that's geico.com even
a rosenbaum can do it listen you were
talking about i mean like
15 minutes ago you said something about
you know when we're doing sweet november
and that scene got cut down to two
minutes it was 20 minutes
have there been roles where you're like
when you watch like
what the [ __ ] what happened to that [ __ ]
have there been moments where you're
like oh it was so great and it's gone
and no one told you
yeah yeah always i mean it's not even
just the uh moment well first of all
when i did
harry potter which i loved doing and i
loved the people who made it was it was
nothing but an
unending pleasure i stopped reading the
books because there were fabulous bits
in the books of course didn't make it to
the screenplay because
otherwise the films would have been 900
hours long um
but but not in those films but in other
things you know
as you know as an actor part of what you
do is you you're shaping
a story like when you're telling a joke
you're kind of you're gauging
calibrating in order for the right bits
to come at the right time in the right
way
and then you see it and the middle has
been put at the end and the end is at
the beginning
and you know or they've altered the
timing so you can cut to someone else
you don't see the reaction
really if you want control over your
performance uh you've got to be on stage
because
uh it's it's a director and an editor's
medium
and it's very rare unless you do a
single take somewhere that the
performance is ever going to be the
performance that you felt that you gave
and then there's the other thing which
is to give a really good performance you
shouldn't really be aware of anything
you're doing
you kind of lose yourself in them you
still know where the mark is and you're
not really punching someone or were you
but but you also shouldn't really be
uh editing your head or aware of it so
when you watch your back it could be a
surprise and not what you thought you
were doing
or not what it looks like you know do
you i don't know i mean
i i try not to think about acting
anymore you know that awful thing that
happens when you get on a set and some
young actor and
have completely prepared their
performance and it's it's fabulous an
exquisite piece
of self sculpture and you could just
drop your pants and take a [ __ ] on their
head and it would not alter
one beat you know that set could be on
fire it doesn't nothing could pull your
nose off
and they're going to do that thing
because they've worked it out with their
manager or their acting coach i've
worked the people have an acting coach
on setting
i try to do no preparation whatsoever i
know the story
you know and i trust myself to be in the
moment i hope that they're going to be
alive at the moment
and whatever happens happens you know
and so um
same with the edit you just have to let
go of it you know our experience our
the pleasure we should get should be
just the release of doing it
you know the release of dancing singing
you know acting
sh painting should be the doing of it
and then just let go and if i could i
would never watch any of it
and i wouldn't care if no one ever saw
any of it but as long as i
kept getting the opportunity to do it
again really so you sincerely
just doing it for you is the pleasure
you don't need to see it
i've been with you on a set look it's i
i don't know how to apportion the pie
but like
part of the place is we get to be part
of this community this little village
that comes together it's a
group of friends it's not like a
non-working working environment
it feels like you're hanging out we are
doing the most childish job on the set
child-like job
so it doesn't feel responsible we're not
you know transplanting organs here
anything and uh
we need to keep ourselves loose and
having fun and our emotions close to the
surface so
laughing is close to tears and so people
are always kind of clowning around
enjoying themselves it's very social
then
then there's the bit where you get to
play like all humans would play if we
were let completely off the leash
and like kids do play we get to play
pretend and feel feel what it's like to
have another person's thoughts and needs
and wants and
uh and kind of unpick the human
condition and yeah and paint pictures
with with the
the building blocks of emotion and stuff
i have this okay
this is gonna sound like a non-sequitur
is not i don't think you know the thing
about good acting bad acting
are people doing it well and that's
judging ourselves are we doing it well
i had a seminal experience i was at
drama school and i was in the common
room
the kind of hangout room with jukebox
and top i think i like
bumped out of a lesson whatever you call
it playing cookie unless i'm sitting
there smoking a big joint
and in the doorway right the other side
of the room where there's two people
from the year above the graduating year
and they're rehearsing some
scene like a really dramatic acting
shouting arguing crying scene
it was just [ __ ] horrible the guy god
bless him was a terrible actor he should
have been told
within a day of arriving at drama school
listen we made a terrible mistake
you know we could get your name down
we'd be confused with someone else
you're never going to be an actor you
don't have the thing whatever it is
it doesn't say anything about you as a
human being you just can't say your own
name inside commencing it's not going to
happen
when i was watching him do this waving
of his arms and shouting and stupid
things his voice i was thinking
it's just cruel pushing about the world
she was pretty good but but it was he
was awful anyway
it was ruining the joint and it was
harsh in my bar so i thought i've got to
get out
and i got up and i walked past him to
leave the room and i realized they were
having a real argument
and they were crying and shouting and
screaming each other best friends having
it falling out
and it was a revelation to me because
that is as good acting as
anybody will ever do ie he was 100
emotional and present i just didn't
particularly like the way he looked or
sounded
something about him felt artificial to
me right so when i watch myself on
screen
or other people it doesn't matter what i
think of what's going on i might think
that person's interesting or true and so
the next person person next to me thinks
that's ridiculous and fake so i'm no
judge of what other people would think
of me anyway
all i can do all i can control is in the
moment am i feeling it
am i honestly trying to change the other
character's mind
am i trying to make them love me or hate
me me assessing later on whether i think
i've done it well and what reviewers
think of it
is so out of my control there's no point
thinking about it it's hard though
especially in the beginning i think that
takes maturity yeah it's a nightmare
because in the beginning you want the uh
awareness you want the you know the
the articles written about oh hey he was
great in this and he did this it still
feels good but
should you be getting sort of enveloped
in it the bad ones you get the good
stuff
it's great and you get addicted to it
you get the bad ones
it really sucks it kind of breaks i
don't have the courage or strength of
character
not to look at them um i've generally
had pretty good ones
but it doesn't make the slightest
difference i can read and now online
social media there's a billion reviews
of things
i can read hours and hours of good stuff
and one person goes that accent sucked
and i just walk around crushed by
it you know so i showed you my friend
lenny james you know the adalani james
who's in uh
fear the walking dead he was in walking
dead yeah um doesn't read reviews
doesn't read him doesn't look at them
not interesting you believe in him i
believe it'll be healthy you believe
that i do he's like my brother i love
him i trust him
[ __ ] if he lied to me i'd be horrified i
don't think he does um but so yeah i i
had this early lesson about reviews
i i was a student not even a drama
student as a law student
and uh we're taking a play to the
edinburgh festival which is this giant
arts festival in scotland
thousands of things go on you can't get
reviews because there's thousands of
things but you don't get an audience
without review so it's a nightmare
and back in the day when i did when i
was young there were only two things
that reviewed you there was two
newspapers one
broadsheet one tabloid so we open at
lunch time
it's this good play you know there's a
lot of unity and swearing we thought was
brilliant we're students a lot you know
a lot of like
a lot of sex and all this stuff and at
midnight
the broadsheet newspaper came out and
that first day we have five people in
the audience
we're six on stage five in the audience
and uh
midnight we're at this party where all
the performers used to go
and they would come in and dump the
newspapers at midnight everyone would
descend like vultures rip it to pieces
see if they got a review
but they're only reviewing like 10 shows
a day in the thousands so you know
[ __ ] me we got a review first day five
percent we get a review and it says
this is the worst piece of [ __ ] i've
ever seen in my life
these people should be shot they're what
gives student drama a bad name
avoid it like the plague so we all
we've got the rest of the summer doing
the show when we walk up onto this
mountain in the middle of the bedroom
we're called off the seat we take some
tequila
probably some things that were illegal
at the time we sit up on the mountain
just so depressed
we come down to five o'clock in the
morning and outside uh a news agent but
of course you know a candy shop number
is um
piles of the tabloid newspaper the
shop's not open yet so they're just
sitting there on the street
you grab one we still be opening it and
unbelievably
we've been reviewed in that too which
means two of the five people in the
audience were reviewers
and it went this is the greatest thing
i've ever seen electrifying theater
pools no punches
go and line up around the block with the
rest of us to watch these stars of
tomorrow
and we got both reviews we put them on a
poster we fly posted all over the town
where these two people saw the same show
make your own mind up we sold out but it
was an early lesson
that none of it means [ __ ] none of it
it's somebody's opinion
they want to look clever they've come up
with a good pun a bit of alliteration
they don't care about you and the work
you've done they just care about reading
their column you know so you shouldn't
look at it that's
enough do you have great stories you've
been shocking the same stories
for 30 years you know well here's a
review for you
my mother yeah well i say what was that
show you loved with jason isaacs
brotherhood he is my favorite
he played a real badass michael caffey
get it now on hulu i've never heard my
mom
oh she's going to like really
good show not known enough ended too
soon and i'm like all right shut up i
just wanted to know what the [ __ ] the
story of all my television series not
known enough
excited one but yeah yeah two years here
or one year what do you mean you ran for
i would have been like 25 years you're
playing later
no seven seven years i left after seven
definitely they're never gonna be on
three
okay well i mean you know you were uh
lucious malfoy so [ __ ] you
but it's not i'll tell you what i have
done though but you took my voice
service this is a strange thing to say
you're lex luthor
oh yeah i'd be like luther russell
superman batman
i've been all the dc people but on a
microphone you alex luther well
and he was pretty awesome brilliant
thank you thank you
but uh what i was going to say was i
mean that's your opinion
yeah exactly you know i mean
one of the things that i've been lucky
about in my you know uh an actor's
career is
so easy i could look at i could paint a
picture of
tremendous uh i wouldn't do it on a
podcast because it's not very inspiring
but
i could go oh woe is me all the things
i've missed out on or i haven't got
they've gone bad they were canceled or i
could go
how amazingly lucky i am i've done all
these fabulous things the truth is you
can wake up every morning and you just
can decide if you're lucky enough or if
not you use some tools whether to be
grateful
you can be ungrateful you can feel
compare yourself to other people you
think
have better lives they probably don't or
you can
just appreciate but i was going to say
one of the things i've been able to do
in my career such as it is
often is choose because i've not been
broke
and that's a huge big deal and one of
the reasons that happened
is that very early on i started doing
voiceovers i had a voice-over agent i
was doing commercials it meant that when
i was offered jobs
where i thought the part was [ __ ] not
small but
bad i didn't do them so some of the
praise i've got from your mum for
instance
there is because i was free enough not
doing other shitty things to go
that is a brilliant script and that is a
brilliant part
and i was lucky enough to get offered it
but if you're not able
to pick and choose the really good parts
and you're not like enough to come your
way
it doesn't matter how good an act you
are you'll never have a break
wow you know so it's i mean i was lucky
i i was after the patriot when i came to
work with you
i was offered every one-dimensional bad
guy in hollywood opposite all of the
kind of big alpha male guys because i've
just been opposite building
really well-written parts right where
you were that you rejected what roles
after that that came to you any big ones
that you rejected after the patriot
oh yeah you can't say things like that
yeah all right just did them i'm a bit
dumb i should have done them for the
money and to cement my status
instead i went to the play about the
northern irish peace process i played a
in a third bleed drag queen i did a
bunch of indie things
i probably should have listened to my
agent and gone just do three or four of
these things and i was going well
they're done
they're part the patriot was a
brilliantly complicated wonderful guy
and the story and mel gibson and roland
gave him status i came on screen and
shot a bunch of kids i
burned a church but lots of the other
villains i was offered were so
way for thin i would have looked bad in
it and i wouldn't get any other work i i
in retrospect
it was dumb i should have taken jobs
made money and no one's
you know playing three-dimensional
career chess i could've done some good
stuff afterwards
but i was too so proud and picky
i wanted only to do things i thought
were great and that's really been
consistently the story of
most of what every now and again i just
do a piece of [ __ ] because it's a good
check or it's a nice holiday but
mostly i try and curate for my own ego
and pride
if i can't be the most famous or richest
person in the world i can at least look
back at the work i've done
and gone that's good stuff and that's
interesting and those are interesting
parts
and when the credits run people can have
a conversation absolutely i mean is
there one role that you were up for
just say you were up for it that offered
you could lie
but just the role out there that was one
of the ones that you're like
i should have i should have talked to
them oh [ __ ] me you're kidding me i
could write a book about the things that
i didn't do
all right i either passed on there went
on to be global smashers
oh nearly the here's the worst one which
i can't obviously put the name in
because someone else did it and whatever
but here's what
i'm um brotherhood went to three seasons
they kind of wanted to cancel it after
two seasons really they gave us a
truncated third season
late in the day they went you know what
you can do eight episodes because there
was a writer's strike and there was a
writer striker they didn't have any
material and developed everything so
they let us limp on for a third season
which is great it's good work but
i don't think they really want to do any
more of it in the period of time when it
wasn't going to happen again
somebody wrote a show that went on to be
um
one of the most successful and awarded
shows in the world and they wrote it
with a picture of me
on the cork board as they wrote it and
uh they were like that you were the
being that's a picture me up there and
they approached me and said
hey you don't know me but i'm x uh and
i've written this
pilot that you know i wrote with you in
mind but you weren't available
congratulations on the third season of
brotherhood and i went oh that's great
what uh what did you write and they went
oh what's your show about
this other thing and i went oh good luck
with that thinking well that's never
going to be anything and then it is now
there are cabinets full of awards for it
and that is the one that got away
because it's a great
great show and it's a great great part
on the other hand oh
you have to be honest and go if i had
done it maybe it wouldn't be successful
maybe the actor that did it is the
reason it became successful and it
wouldn't have been
good with me in it maybe i would have
blown it i always say and you could
agree with me or not but
it's the perfect storm you know like you
know i've
talked about it you want you in the
patriot if if uh heath ledger wasn't
very good
or it wasn't shot that great or you're
you know whatever that all these things
didn't add up and make it this really
great movie
sure if one thing's missing that could
be enough to break the card down
oh yeah francis ford coppola changed the
score of the godfather
like two weeks before he came out the
score is everything in that stock yeah
genius
now it all just has to happen you know
it's it's it's like when we're doing
publicity for harry potter we go around
you know when we used to go around and
do all this junkies everyone people
would go
so so tell me what do you think the
movies are so successful
what is it about the books that really
works and then people are going
you know all my esteemed fellow cast
members are going well you know
it's about loyalty about friendships
right so's a million other [ __ ]
things
and they've got kids and they've got
magic and they've got who knows
it's the ley lines met something
happened and if you could repeat it they
won't repeat it
so who knows when things work and why
they work but i think it always starts
with a good script
i've never been in anything good that
came from a bad script ever
yeah yeah can you think of something
said that well
usually uh when i go in i'm thinking
well i bet they could do something with
this
you know maybe they're who knows i mean
certainly there are movies or scripts
that you look at and they're like that
can't be good and the director's so
uh inventive creative technological that
all of a sudden becomes this huge thing
and you're like
you know you read the movie like cabin
in the woods i like horror movies and
you're like oh god i don't know this is
like
and then you literally oh no that worked
i love that film it was so fun say what
i read that i didn't
think was that funny but partly because
i was asked to audition for a part but
only one eye appeared it was all
prosthetic
is galaxy quest i remember thinking it
was kind of funny
i hadn't at the time been obviously in
star trek or been to conventions or seen
any of that stuff but
but you know i got some understanding of
it but the aliens
weren't even remotely funny on the page
there's nothing about them they just
spoke like androids
when i watched the film which is utter
genius from start to finish
every word love it and i thought wow i
should have but i don't think i should
have seen it and they must have come up
with that rehearsal i don't know how
they did it yeah i went in there for
that like three times for that
alien i come from the they didn't let
you know where the whole thing
the way they did it was genius i didn't
even think of that i did something else
that was kind of corny and
probably would have ruined the movie
you're very good at voice i remember
your impressions
vividly really have you updated them
with any new people or is it still
because when they die you're [ __ ] well
i remember uh
i remember keanu when we were working
with piano i just remember that's when i
started to develop the kana reeves
impression
and i loved him i just remember us
sitting in the room and i we we love him
him adore him and he's the best but i
just remember
you had to carry charlize or we had to
carry charlize into the bathroom she had
cancer and
we're we're sitting in there and kissing
let's let's be honest she's a big glass
yeah she's a bag of bones it's very easy
yes it's very easy she's very thin
very lightweight uh but we're sitting
there
i thought you remember because she's so
tall but we're sitting there and then
keanu they say action he comes in he has
a scene just goes
sarah and he does this sarah i know
doctors
and he gets [ __ ] and he hits the wall
he's like pat's like are you okay can i
you need it
you need another you need to admit it or
something he's like no no i've got this
action sarah
i know doctors [ __ ] [ __ ]
and he kind of hits the wall again and
then he goes no i got this
can he are you sure yeah action
sarah i know doctors
yeah i think that was it and you i
remember all of us looking at you like
what what it was just a funny moment he
was
uh he was a phenomenon i i thought
he is inside of you
is brought to you by athletic greens
i wanted to do my announcer voice for
that i
i love this stuff i've told you i gave
you some of this stuff
in my life man without athletic greens
i'm not getting my nutrients
i'm not getting my minerals this stuff
tastes good it's easy you drop into
water this is a no-brainer folks it
really is a no-brainer
um most of us wake up and maybe have a
piece of peanut butter toast
like i do or you have some coffee you're
not putting good things in your body
right off the bat but what if you did
if you did you'd feel better and i do
feel better after doing this
and it becomes a routine in your life
with so many stressors in life it's
difficult to maintain effective
nutritional habits and give our bodies
the nutrients it needs to thrive
busy schedules poor sleep exercise
stress or simply not eating enough of
the right
foods one scoop of athletic greens
contains
75 vitamins minerals and whole
food-sourced ingredients wait
75 that's right michael including a
multivitamin multi-mineral probiotic
green superfood blend and more and all
these guys
work together to fill the nutritional
gaps in your diet
increase your energy increase your focus
that's what i need in my life i need
more focus
more energy and i'm getting older this
is these are vital
aids and digestion and supports a
healthy immune system
all without the need to take multiple
products right now athletic greens is
doubling down on supporting your immune
system during the winter months they're
offering my audience a
free one-year supply of vitamin d
and five free travel packs with your
first purchase if you visit
my link today you'll basically never
have to buy vitamin d again
so whether you're looking for peak
performance or better health covering
your bases with athletic greens
makes investing in your energy immunity
and gut health each day simple tasty and
efficient
simply visit athletic greens dot com
slash
y-o-u and join health experts athletes
and health-conscious go-getters around
the world who make a daily commitment
to their health every day again simply
visit athleticgreens.com
y-o-u and get your free year supply of
vitamin d
and five free travel packs today
athleticgreens.com
y-o-u inside of you is brought to you by
capsule
michael isn't going to the pharmacy the
worst the worst it's terrible
it's terrible i i hate uh running out of
prescriptions and then go oh i gotta
stop by they're
waiting that line and they got the
little feet things for the social
distancing so you're kind of like
six feet away and you're like down aisle
four
waiting to get in line for your
prescription you know it's awesome
what's awesome you don't have to
freaking do that anymore with
capsule i mean isn't it all about doing
things that are easier in your life or
make your life easier
capsule's here capsules a new kind of
pharmacy that hand delivers your
prescription
the same day for free to start visit
capsule.com it only takes 15 seconds to
sign
up and when your prescription's ready
capsule will text you to schedule free
delivery at a time that you choose
then a capsule courier hand delivers
your medication to your door
straight from their pharmacy in a
tamper-proof package
it's totally secure and that's great if
you have any questions you can call text
or email with an expert
pharmacist it's that simple i don't know
what you're doing i don't know what i'm
doing but i'm not
going to the pharmacy anymore i'm
talking a capsule
guys no more waiting in line no more
driving to the pharmacy number for
getting
refills done capsule is saving your life
capsule accepts all major insurance and
is currently available in new york city
in the surrounding tri-state area
los angeles austin boston chicago
and the twin cities and other cities are
coming very soon
to sign up visit capsule.com to get your
prescription hand delivered today
for free that's capsule.com
inside of you is brought to you by true
underdog
podcast raised in a trailer park with no
clear path to success
kicked out of high school multiple times
faced with becoming a father in his
teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog
after hearing the words no or you can't
too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies
with his most recent venture power home
solar
skyrocketing on a path to becoming a
billion dollar enterprise
join us as waller a four-time
entrepreneur of the year winner
shares motivational tips and inspiring
stories
and business building lessons from the
ground up he shares his life experiences
and that of his high profile guests to
help others
better themselves as waller will tell
you there's no elevator to success
that climb only happens one step at a
time
let every true underdog podcast be that
step that elevates you
scared money won't make money learn
about failure
learn about entrepreneurship learn about
never quitting or making excuses
it's real it's raw it's motivational
check out
true underdog podcast at
trueunderdog.com
or anywhere you get your podcasts
let me ask you you said you don't
prepare you said you well you know when
you
i i know that's a loose term it's like
you know preparing oh i don't look at
the lines
and i don't think about what's going to
happen wait a minute but i know the
lines
you know the lines when you say how long
does it take you to memorize lines
i never learn lines i never look at them
like i've i've read the script
you know i know roughly what's happening
i don't know where isn't the story
because
you shoot out of sequence always
obviously so i don't know where i come
from what's happening before what's
happening
i get to the set i have the sides which
is the little piece of paper and i just
i familiarize myself
as we're make doing some choreography or
blocking and and uh
and then i i just sort of know them and
reach for them on it because
i don't i'm making this [ __ ] up when i'm
talking to you so i don't know what i'm
gonna say next so i have a very very
loose grasp of the lines and
occasionally i've worked with directors
who think oh he's taking it lightly or
he's being an amateur or something but
it's an approach i've learned from much
better more experienced actors that i
just have a
you know i i'm somewhere i know someone
some level beyond consciousness
i know roughly what the shape of it is
but i want to see what happens
well what happens when you have to know
words verbatim like the patriot or
whatever it is and they don't want you
to improvise
and you you have to improvise i mean you
know i do i respect the writer
but just if they make sense and it's
what you would say next because you've
worked because
you know what you're thinking if it's
good writing you know because you know
whatever says what they're thinking they
say what they want
they say things to try and get the
effect they want from the person they're
talking to
they make sense then they come out
they're natural if you keep stumbling
over the same
point or transitions because maybe you
haven't got your thoughts right
or maybe sometimes the words need
tweaking so
so you just you know do the work first
to make sure it's not you so you read
the script a few times you know it you
know this character
and you you say when you get on set
you'll go over in the makeup trailer
you'll
kind of like go through it in blocking
but you never really
know you guys should just watch the
youtube just to see what jason did with
the microphone
uh but you never really see that my
right now i get anxiety thinking about
that even if it's pages of dialogue and
i've never held up a shoot
now they've never had to wait while i go
wait a second got this down i mean look
if it's
if it's reams of medical stuff that
you've got to learn or in star trek
when i was a captain of star trek i
would constantly try and give the very
scientific gobbledygook away to other
people like it would have been if he
said that to me
but um right yeah i just i mean i i i
can learn things very quickly i have a
lot of ram and around all the other way
or whatever it is i can i can get there
and look at the stuff in the trailer and
i know the words but
what i don't want to do is have a shape
for it in my head i don't want to have a
performance
before i'm engaged with the other person
it's like you know
you practice having sex by yourself and
then slot someone else in
that's not the way it works and you know
the best acting teacher i ever had i was
so intrigued when i heard um
uh jamie jamilyn siegel on your podcast
saying she's gone back to acting classes
now you know
um because nobody in britain does that
you know you leave drama school you
never do classes again but the best
the best teacher i ever learned from uh
this director
never told us a thing to do never once
suggested anything we should do
uh in our performance he just kept on
asking us what we're trying to change in
the other person
and then when he started answering go
don't tell me show me
uh and i i'm i wonder if you found this
to be the same the best performances
i've ever seen on the film set
are always off camera it's always the
person off camera 100
in life now i'm talking right i know
there's a camera pointing at me but i'm
looking at a picture of you
because what i'm really trying to do is
connect with you get a reaction from you
i have i have scenarios in my head that
play out one is that you go
this is amazing you know that's my
optimum scenario
the nightmare scenario is i'm looking at
you and i see that you're actually
texting someone while i'm talking you
know somewhere between the two is the
drama
and why i'm still talking you know and
uh you can't do that [ __ ] by yourself in
the trailer you can only do that with
another person and see
whether they're alive you know whether
whether it's working whether you're
going to get to make
them apologize or say i love you or stop
being angry or whatever the scene
requires
whatever yeah i have a very loose graph
of the word so then they get there and i
see
see what happens what percent of how
many actors do
you come across big actors who just
really don't give you much off camera
who just kind of throw it away and like
you know you're kind of on your own and
can you deal with that are you good
can you go over a hundred
it's not it's not that people don't give
you a lot of off camera it's that if you
shoot
their close-up last if they'd be doing
wide they might be working themselves
into it
so when you finally do their close-up
someone's close-up whether it's the star
of the film or someone who doesn't quite
you know hasn't been around enough
doesn't know how this game works
they only really really focus on what's
going on for them and they close up or
when it gets to their close-up they
suddenly go oh this is the bit where i
better cry
well i better shout i better do
something interesting in my close-up
that's spectacular and
you know uh is worthy of the ticket
price and you go
well if i don't you're gonna [ __ ] do
that when i shot my reaction to it
you know when i'm just talking and now
i'm doing your close-up and now you're
sobbing
i want to be talking to a crying person
it's a whole different thing
so good actors generous actors theater
actors
uh um will very often right from the
beginning
be present um it's a sign of
inexperience i think
sometimes you know uh schematic
selfishness but mostly an experience
that people don't really haven't found
the heart of the thing
until they do their own close-up and
what they should be doing is finding it
always and
finding it off camera always and i've i
find that most you know acting is a very
generous thing
it's there's very few people that are
entirely selfish
about the performance because they know
you're only ever as good as the other
person in the scene
yeah you know you can't be good in the
scene where someone else is not
believable so if you don't give it to
them
then they don't give it to you and then
the thing dies
hey you know when you worked uh i i
think about like the set of the patriot
i'm just imagining it
and like it's you know it's like your
first real big role you were an event
horizon you'd
done a lot of stuff but like i've been i
don't i've done leads
in british tv shows right i mean
patriots was my first big role in a big
american
right this was like holy [ __ ] everybody
in the world's gonna see this and this
is the
the bad guy you're the darth vader of
the patriot and
you know it's so you're sitting there
and you're working with the heat ledger
and mel gibson and you know
are you one of those guys that when
you're the bad guy you have to sit away
from everybody you don't want to get too
talky or you could just jump in well
some people are like that i've read a
lot
about that or are you sitting around
talking to heath and mel and got along
great
so we we flew out there early to uh
south carolina mel heath and i
uh and an ad i think and for a feels
like a month but maybe it was a couple
of weeks
all we did was ride horses sword fight
load and fire muskets and throw
tomahawks
and every day we go back to where we
were staying we look at each other and
go we're getting [ __ ] paid for this
it was just we had a fantastic time and
uh
no it's an incredibly convivial
collegiate set i mean i've been on those
sets
where the directors think that in order
to create the kind of alpha macho
tension that is needed on camera
they need to be screaming and shouting
the set needs to be tense roland wasn't
like that he was on top of his craft
mel is a great actor you know he's many
things but he's a great very generous
actor he's a guy that's really giving it
off screen
and uh he's one of those i remember they
did the scene with um
heath dying in his arms you know and it
will be injured i think everybody's
dying no i think he's injured and so
and he uh and it's a huge set i mean
like there's a crane coming down like
five other people coming out of the hill
on a horse and
ends up in a close-up of him and he's
standing smoking a [ __ ]
and uh smoking a cigarette for the
american listeners and um
yeah and he's telling some hilariously
blue off-color story and uh gag and then
they go ready and
he runs over they go action he he
sits down he kneels down and he keems
when he rips his soul out there's no
oh i'm going to do some crying noises
mel goes there he's got these wells of
rage obviously and pain he can access
and he just the tears are projectiling
out of his eyes and he's holding him
they go cut
10 of the horses went left instead of
right they're going to reset and he
comes over he finishes the joke
he must have done 10 takes like that and
it was never him getting he was getting
it perfect every time
because the horses were wrong because
the camera didn't do it right he never
said hey listen guys i've done it now
you've gotta
that's enough and um we were playing
chess and scrabble in between them
telling jokes and
i've always been like that one set
sometimes there are people who want to
keep themselves themselves and go
somewhere i
my best experiences have been not just
you joking to distract people
but you're keeping all of you keeping
that sense of play so close to the
surface
that you can laugh you can cry you can
rage you can murder
it's all they're all part of a spectrum
of they're all they're all
connected in a way they're about being
loose and letting things flow through
you so
no i was on the set i what i was amazed
by on that film
is that roland the director and dean the
producer and mel
gave me a seat at the top table if i had
an idea we did it if they thought it was
good you know and anytime i wanted to
change the script or come up with
something
i remember we were going to um i was
riding i was meant to get off my horse
and go into the church
and tell them all that i knew they'd
been collaborators and i was going to
burn them
and i said to roland and you know i
could ride into the church
how about that for disrespect and i
think one of the designers or someone's
actually said i don't think we made the
doors big enough for robin hold on
what do you mean i said well doesn't ask
if i ride in the church i tell them that
they will you know
they can save themselves if they tell me
where the guy is
and then once they tell me i'll go thank
you and i ride out and burn it and he
goes
yeah sure i like it and then the someone
else came over and said
i don't think the door's big enough he
says sure so we shoot it later make the
doors bigger
and i ended up writing the chest they
gave me a completely
the license to come up with stuff that i
thought was fun if they thought it was
fun we did it too
and that's that made you feel good huh
but also
well done the best creative work comes
when you empower everyone
i watch chris columbus that lovely
lovely man and wonderful director
i watched someone harry potter ask 11
year olds some 12 year olds who never
react to people what do they think
they've been good ideas for the scene
what do they think and you know
i saw the director of um i didn't see
what's called the oa on netflix
and zhao his genius director who i adore
he had a number of people who'd never
acted before you know uh ian who's in
other people and he'd ask them what they
wanted to say you know the character
better than me what do you think
it's not that there's nobody in charge
far from it's the very opposite
but if you empower everybody then you
can take the best of their ideas and and
that was what the set of the patriot was
like
melvin's always encouraging me to be you
know he wanted me to direct the stunt
stuff he just interacted braveheart
it was like the stunts guys came and
showed us the fight and he goes no no no
no jace
you take over tell them i'm like these
people have been doing this job for long
that i've been alive he went
tell them what we what the fight needs
to be so it's just
anybody listening the point is not me
telling showbiz stories if you're doing
anything creative
empower everyone no one knows better
than anybody else i always say that's
absolutely true you know whatever you're
doing i i
defer to other people real people who
know what they're doing hey
you know when you're doing a scene and
you're i look at the camera guy and i go
hey john
is that funny he's like not really
i'm like well it's not funny it's not
working if john's not laughing he's our
audience
john [ __ ] knows i don't know i i
would take odds with you that i think
there's something about comedy if it's
funny on the set
it probably isn't funny at home that's
true that's that's true
that could very much get in the crew
laughing it's just like you get the crew
applauding at a big performance
it's a big performance and it's not
gonna work on camera the crew shouldn't
see it the camera sees your secrets the
crew shouldn't see your secrets i think
that's you know that's happened where
you're like everybody's laughing it's
just fun
it's it's gone both ways but i think you
just have to know when something's funny
and trust it
and not try to overdo it and that could
be very difficult unless you're with the
you know you have the right direction
the thing is people try to be funny
you've got funny bones funny people are
funny
and people are unfunny it doesn't i
don't care who wrote their [ __ ]
script they're just never gonna get a
laugh
they just don't get it just don't get
the rhythm of it hey this is called [ __ ]
talking with jason isaacs
this is rapid fire you could be as fast
as you want if you want to talk about it
you can
uh my patrons my lovely patrons emily s
what's your favorite line or insult your
character on harry potter sad
oh i remember being in hagrid's house
and it's because i like the vowel
you know i came up with this torturous
voice for lucious malfoy it was meant to
make you hate him before you understood
a word
and i said i was in his house and i went
you call this a heist
i just remember that say it again i like
it
you call this a heist
maisha you've had a long and very
diverse career is there any actor that
you absolutely loved
loved working with and why the one that
just comes right off the tip of your
tongue
oh god well lady james ended up being
one of my best friends so i loved
working i did a tv series but in the
movies
i loved working with richard harris
because he's he's a god and i've been in
a drama school with his son
jared and when the days when richard
came to watch us in the plays were like
three sets of white front stays he like
it was [ __ ] terrifying this oscar
winner was coming to watch us
and then i got to do a scene with him
before he died which i love i just
started watching the crown i hadn't seen
him five episodes in jared harris
jared's fantastic oh man there's a
fantastic he was a fantastic drama
school he was what they call a dangerous
actor people think dangerous actors are
people that you know swing the sword too
close to your face no
it's people who make bold choices and
could fall flat on their ass
but could be genius he was always brave
for his choices that's
that's difficult most people want to
play it safe right yeah
you obviously want to get the next job
maddie waggs
uh you're so good at playing a villain
and making the audience and instantly
hate you
the patriots soldier harry potter my
question is what draws you
to the role of the villain and you
mentioned this it has to be well written
and not just kind of paper thin
but what character what character traits
make uh for a good villain
just believability you know lucy's
malfoy is just a racist he's a scared
old racist with you know uh ridiculous
blonde hair does that remind you of
anyone
and those people they look in the mirror
they think they're right
if you play in a character who's just
doing [ __ ] to make the audience boo
they won't even notice you you know
white supremacists think they're right
he's trying to make hogwarts great again
this is a guy who thinks
the world was better when people like me
ruled things and he can see it's moving
so i believe him the guy in the patrol
is trying to win the war he's scared of
going home because
his aristocratic family is broke you've
got there's got to be a reason why
you're doing things
did you love working with tom pelton i
still love tom felton i taught him all
the time i know i do stuff online all
the time he might do it actually we
might do a podcast together
i think i could never pin him down we're
always in different countries different
times uh yeah
he was a gorgeous kid so lovely i felt
terrible bullying him on screen
um and he's turned into a lovely young
man yeah matthew j do you
prefer playing the villain or the hero
good guy role which one you like
uh i like the bits that are so well
written that i get the credit for a
writer who's created a three-dimensional
part
good answer leanne p you've played a
variety of characters over the years
which one do you identify with the most
um probably i did angels in america the
first productions on stage
and i was i went in to talk to him about
playing prior who was the drag queen who
was eight
and i said uh you know he has a very
wingy neurotic jewish boyfriend
i never get to play that and it's so
much closer than to who i am
so i maybe louis in angels is closer
than any of the past i've played
carly t was armageddon as much fun to
make as it was to watch
and what's your favorite memory from
that shirt i know i heard it was a
painting [ __ ] no
i mean the only reason why is i was
offered one of the astronauts and i
couldn't do it because i was working
so they very kindly came back and said
why don't you play professor quincy i'm
like okay great and they
my agent goes you should take it because
it's eight days work over six months
but they'll pay for you to be in los
angeles we can look for other work
they'll actually pay for you to be in a
hotel like oh that's awesome
i go to my first day's work michael's
very nice he's very flattering about how
i do
the one day that i have a lot of lines
and he goes do we have you for the run
of the picture
i said well i'm i mean i'm here for six
months but i'm only doing 18. no no
[ __ ]
i'm going gonna put you in every day
we'll give you like a clipboard we'll
put you next to billy bob we'll throw
you online occasionally
i just i almost vomited on the spot
because i was there
for six months mostly as an extra every
day uh and you know every two months
down the line
and that wasn't that much fun janelle b
huge fan of the oa there it is
as it is such an original show please
tell me if it
please tell me it really wasn't
cancelled and the finale is just a plot
to set up season three
i emailed you interesting nice to be
inside of me i don't want this be
therapy
uh i said i'll come into your shop yeah
is that a question the first therapeutic
i i could weep the oa i loved it i think
it's so
staggeringly original and beautiful and
human and i've been doing this job for a
long time and a lot of
still a lot of great stories with great
people i've never come across
anything like their way and i don't know
if i was you know other people watched
it
some people watching most people i know
who watched it a
watched all eight episodes of season one
then all eight episodes in one go
because they couldn't stop
and were profoundly affected by it in
ways that they can't even explain
i i thought it was you know i said the
ley lines met with harry potter the lay
lines met with the oa
well that's all and brick came up with
it was something magic they had all five
seasons mapped out
never heard of that before really in
great detail and uh
i don't know i was i was blown away and
by this stage i don't really get blown
away by many things i like oh that's
nice i'll do that oh that's interesting
i i just felt like i'd arrived fresh off
the boat from another planet
because i felt like they reinvented
storytelling if you haven't seen
it watch both seasons please watch both
seasons and of course brotherhood my
mother isn't going to make me watch i'm
going to watch not that she has to make
me watch
your taste she has but children and tv
shows but you don't usually get like you
said connected to something like that
where
emotionally did you feel did you cry or
did you were you were really upset were
you hurt that that when we were canceled
yeah i was devastated
yeah devastated by it by the way i
wasn't
i wasn't the first choice for the parts
they cast someone else they shot with
him he replaced him
you know i i lucked into that and uh i
couldn't believe my good fortune it was
one of those things that
uh like i said it was the doing of it
being around people that creative that
generous
that supportive that free in their
thinking but you know about
i don't feel like this but most things
i'm on like i'm trying to help my god
talk to write a script at the moment
you know somebody comes up with stuff
i'm filtering it through the
thousands of hours of drek that i have
made and seen and thought about and i go
hey why don't you and i come up with
some ideas based on [ __ ] i've seen
before i felt like
they were untouched by all of the you
know the poison of millions of hours of
procedural tv that i i've watched
and processed i felt like they meant it
to you and i i'm just being on set with
them telling
this story so originally and the
atmosphere
in which we told it uh was enough for me
you know it turns out it was a giant
cult hit could you be a giant cult i
don't know sure and i was crushed i
didn't get to but
the agents were thrilled not that it was
cancelled because they liked it but like
you're not lead you know you've you've
got out of it what you're going to get
out of it i remember hearing that from a
representative
going you don't understand why i do this
job i'm not trying to i'm not to build
something on a ladder or
you know get the checks to go up or my
quote to go up
i'm in this job because i love exploring
human beings
with talented people and this it's never
been better than this
um so yeah i was crushed crushed when it
was over oh i'm sorry
it just means i keep that child alive i
keep that over in
look at me i'm you know my age i'm i
talk like a uh
you know an overshoot eight-year-old
because i keep myself enthusiastic
you are last question kelly s what was
it working with
what was it like working with the late
great alan rickman
i was stupidly for years
scared [ __ ] or something being timid
dated by me just being the way he spoke
you know
um he's actually the loveliest most
generous man
very fiercely committed to political
causes you know center left and leopard
causes
when he found someone he wanted a
champion or help he really helped
financially and with his time uh he was
amazing but uh
i never really um i stayed intimidated
by him i
never really got out of got the benefit
out of him that i could have done
because
it was an incredibly friendly set the
best moment of harry potter for me
best but by far was right at the end
we're shooting the
final big battle at hogwarts so
everybody's in all the actors are in
and uh and it rains and so we're there
every day but it's raining and so we
don't shoot
and it being a big budget movie they
don't seem to care which any other film
they'd be
pulling their hair out you know but so
instead of going back to everyone's
train
if it's an american movie everyone would
go back to their trailers and stuff we
all huddled in this tent
the sound of definitely rain they had a
very stale
tea urn like the other your spoon would
stand up in your cup of tea
and we sat there around these electric
heaters and julie walters
told stories about her pig farm and
everybody allen told us
you know jim broadbent was there and uh
imelda wasn't there but to you uh
cambodia was there with so many people
there all the kids were there
um and just told stories you know but
everyone was telling us i was hanging
out like we were doing a touring theater
you know dinner theater production or
something
and every day i get there so i go please
let it be raining today
please let us not shoot this thing it's
just to sit in the company of these
great great actors the theatrical
royalty and the kind of
i don't know if maybe you've noticed
this before but every set
every film every television show exists
on this undercurrent this bed
of terror and anxiety that nobody's
going to watch you know
everyone's going to lose their money the
show is going to be cancelled whatever
it is
and on the harry potters by the time we
got you know halfway through we go
these are the most popular films in the
world we're telling great stories
great scripts in an you know in a great
way and he just
fills you with just confidence to
to to be bold and to dare to do things
and with a great bunch of people so uh
yeah that was my favorite was like work
with alan raymond like it was working
with everyone
i pinched myself myself every day that i
saw my name
on a list on the call sheet with these
people that i
frankly worshipped that is awesome and
and i and i could picture it i pictured
the tent i pictured everybody kind of in
close proximity
i pictured someone just yelling this and
oh yeah and then kind of sharing stories
and
just it feels like camp you know well so
the public think about us when we went
to duke premier the last movie
they had to have like a dozen cinemas
and it was just the biggest thing that
ever happened in trafalgar square and
leicester square were
full of tens of thousands of people and
you know i think sometimes when i don't
know if it happens to you but my friends
go oh my daughter wants to be an actress
and my son's been actually talk to them
because they've seen stuff like that on
tv but that's the life of an actor the
stuff that's lovely is
us in a tent shivering with the rain
outside
sipping tea telling stories as if we
were all starting out students
the fact that four of them have oscars
you know like
there's no status in acting there can't
be states that there shouldn't be status
in a group of players minstrels used to
get kicked out or hung or raped or
whatever
you know we're we're vagabonds we should
be and uh and that's what that felt like
to me
this has been an absolute joy honestly i
wish you all the best people
get to come to america what's yeah
sometimes you have a place to stay
what's going on
any father wait what's your handle
what's your instagram and all that oh
i'm on twitter i'm
at jason's folly it's mostly been
politics for a long time i hope to god
it doesn't have to be for a long time to
come
uh i try to sell promotion i'm tempted
to do easy gags all the time it doesn't
live alongside trump's hideous racism
and uh
intent to destroy the world but
hopefully we'll never mention him again
so at jason's following on instagram
which i
post once every six months from my
daughter it reminds me i'm the real
jason isaac
nice and what's anything coming up i
know it's it's you know quarantined yeah
the film spell this film's coming out
but i mean are they coming out i don't
know
there's one there's a film out now
called skyfi there's a film coming out
next week on amazon i think oh no in
january called dr bird's advice for sad
poets which is a brilliant
uh indie but there's a film in which i
have a much bigger part i'm
incredibly excited about that i uh oh i
can't say
that i'll think about it i was going to
say but it's called mass and it is
the enticing scenario of four people
sitting at a table talking
um two of them are the parents of a kid
who died in a school shooting
and the other two are the parents of the
shooter and uh some years have gone by
and they've not been able to get over it
the kids are the parents of the victim
and their therapists suggest they meet
the parents of the shooter to try and
make him human
and it's one of the most brilliant
pieces of writing and acting
masterclasses
not for me but from the other people
i've ever seen in my life it was just
it was staggering watching them i don't
know how it works as a film i've been
given amazing feedback but you always
are
i that's the one i can't wait to see
that come out of the new year oh [ __ ]
you know what there's a list of things
i don't know this is a bunch of [ __ ] i
want to see i haven't watched it but i'm
going to watch the death of stalin
i want to see that death of silence
there's only amanda yanucci
in the world that could make a satire
about you know
one of the world's most genocidal
maniacs and make it both funny and
respectful of the dead
ryan just went like this my engineer
just went
yeah on that one dude i love you and uh
keep in touch
all my best with the kids and emma and
and just life
and be healthy and safe and thank you
what's dating during pandemic like
oh god we'll we'll discuss uh after okay
okay all right man thanks thanks for
allowing me to be inside with you jason
great to see you we're done
hey thanks for listening uh you know i
appreciate you guys
tuning in and hopefully you enjoy jason
isaacs and you'll stick around for next
week's episode and support the podcast
and um i just want to say i really
appreciate that it was a
really fun interview talking to my old
buddy i remember on sweet november us
going like golfing and
hanging around san francisco uh and then
being transvestites in a movie and it
was uh
it was a treat it was a i definitely
have fond memories of that
working with canneries and charlize
throne and
it was a lot of fun ryan that was a good
episode good editing my friend
oh thank you yeah it was uh you know
he's a private guy and yet i think he
was open
and um very forthcoming is that the
right word yeah
yeah i think he was that's a word i
think it was a word i took word
power and co in high school i remember
ameliorate to become better i remember
exuberant overwhelming with joy
i remember colloquialism
not sure what that one meant i think it
was like
frat is a colloquialism yeah it said for
fraternity
right it's a it's slang it's a fancy
word for slack yeah
colloquialism i tell you my favorite
word yeah defenestrate
defenestrate does that mean take away
that means to throw out of a window
throw out of a window okay defense
straight i was i was close yeah
in a way right right do away with yeah
it's just i defenestrated my father in
smallville
lex luthor defenestrated his father out
of the [ __ ] window that's right
i am the villain of the story um
hey guys this has been a real treat uh
thank you for supporting the band
sunspin go to sunspin.com for all your
merch go to inside of you
online store for all your uh merch for
um the podcast
patreon my lovable awesome patrons hi
out there this is just for you this goes
out to the
awesome patrons who make this show uh
very possible
so i just want to say i love you and all
that stuff you know
i'm a weirdo right now um go to
patreon.com
inside of you and if you also have any
questions you could also go to hello at
inside of you podcast for any
information what are the handles for uh
inside of your podcast inside of you pod
on twitter inside of your podcast on
instagram and facebook
that's correct and they're right here so
you can see them so it's a beautiful
thing
all right here are the wonderful patrons
that uh
if you want to again if you want to join
patreon go to patreon.com inside of you
i'll send you a message but uh these are
the folks that really
support the show and i thank them from
the bottom of my heart also thanks to
westwood one
kelly agnes theresa catrin
um and my good friend ryan and bryce
i can't wait to hug you ryan it's gonna
be a good one i'm looking forward to so
many hugs
yeah we're gonna hug it out here are the
patrons music please
oh there it is right there let's let's
put a little sun spin music on here
instrumental while we're doing it okay
oh yeah you feel that nancy d mary b
leah s trisha f serif
brian h lauren g nico p this is sexy
voice
robin s jerry w robert i jason w stephen
j
kristen k emilia oh allison l jess j
lucas m raj c joshua
d emily s yes cj
p samantha b no
m you were that was a roll right there
buddy
i got it wrong last week too jennifer n
jackie p stacy l
carly h gen s jamal
f janelle b by the way i do that i have
to change page i have to lick my finger
i have to my fingers won't change a
[ __ ] page and people say they hate
those people who do that sometimes i do
that
does it come with age i don't [ __ ]
know dude cause it feels like a dad
thing to do
i've been a dad for 20 years on carrie b
tablet the 272 not to be confused with
seven to 273 ashley ryan kimberly e
mike e marissa and yes el don supremo
dan jack s ramirez beth b
santiago m sir f chad w leanne
[Laughter]
you're good buddy rey hey yes
maya p maisha
that's a hard one i don't know c aisha
matty kendrick f ashley e shannon d matt
w belinda and kevin v james r chris h
amy c dave h samantha s spider-man chase
sheila
g rey a h oh that one's right h
alice's c tablet t misha h tom and henry
s kdf they're all here you can see their
names and you can hear them
and uh liliana a michelle k
hannah b michael s talia m luke h john s
andrew t claire m liz j laura l chad l
rochelle
chad l rochelle nathan e brandel
taylor k neil a uh marlon meg
k janelle p dan and jennifer n almost
done here wayne m
oh jediah oh jetta lorraine g olga
oh my olga c olga ordered a bunch of
shirts
uh with my face on it for her school
olga
you rock corey m um this has been a real
treat
ryan what are we gonna do this week that
is gonna
make us feel better name one thing
you're gonna do for yourself this week
uh i'm gonna actually pick up my goddamn
guitar good because i think you're a
fabulous guitar player and a singer
thank you i do you're very very talented
in many ways
and i think i don't want you to forget
the things you love and the passions you
have because you're tied up with like
lots of work
yep you know i don't want you to stop
working
because then we'd be [ __ ] that'd be
great but
uh i want you to take care of yourself
i'm gonna try and take care of myself
i'm gonna um
i'm gonna try and play some golf that's
good i'm gonna try you know i've been
writing a lot but that's
i gotta st you know i wanna i'm writing
a new song
i'm writing a new song called movie star
and i played it for rob and he loved it
and then rob as uh
bringing his brilliance to it so we'll
be getting that um
anyway have a fabulous week guys we love
you from the hollywood hills
the lifestyles of the mildly famous
lifestyles of the mildly famous and not
so
rich uh i'm michael rosenbaum
i've been ryan taylor yeah i'm ryan tess
and uh have a superb week do something
for yourself love yourself give yourself
a break
we'll be back next week please join us
please subscribe we love you
give a wave thanks for allowing to be
inside of each and every one of you guys
[Music]
thanks